welcome back our guest who's been here
several times but it's the first time
he's ever brought bread with him because
he's gonna be the host of a new Food
Network TV series called baked
premiering on Labor Day two new episodes
have baked every Monday through
September 24th at 10 p.m. Eastern and
10:30 Pacific it is Tom papa good to see
you sir
good to see you my friend so you have
brought two pieces suit loaves of bread
from locally here in Culver City Garage
bread and now you so you are traveling
the country yeah eating pastries and
breads and going to local bakeries
amazing Network I wasn't trying to get a
show I was just baking bread I learned
how to bake sourdough bread at home yes
with my family and then I would travel
as a comedian I would go to different
cities and visit these bakeries just to
learn you know see what I've never had a
hobby before right and they're pretty
obsessing and I started just visiting
them and then the Food Network kind of
caught wind of it okay
and it was a big thing on social media
people were sending me their recipes it
became this thing and now my job is to
travel around the country and eat this
stuff so is it
it is it was this part of an idea maybe
from your buddy Seinfeld comedians and
bakery coffee he just cost boring
because you got Jim Gaffigan and on one
of the episodes yeah so is there are
there guests that are now Jim's the only
guest
you have to twist his arm say hey let's
go to a bakery and eat bread if you go
to New York City and you go into a
doughnut shop there's a 90% chance
you'll see Jim Gaffigan just sitting
right there already sampling the in any
one of them I mean that's what I really
wanted the show to be is just like the
celebration of all this stuff you know
like I started to realize when I was
going around to all these cities went to
Cleveland in New Orleans and all these
places la you don't really need a bakery
in these towns you know what I mean you
really you need police you need fired
upon you don't need a bakery it's a
special little place to just go enjoy
your life well I would think people in
New Orleans would disagree that there
must be a baker they don't even have a
police department it's just awful I saw
sea of love wait a minute hold on a
second so
this starting right now and but it's ah
it's tough to concentrate the bread
smells incredible isn't it amazing it
makes you happy and that's what really
started to bother me right I was I was
making the stuff it was so good and all
of these people would come by and say oh
I can't eat bread I don't eat bread a
candy bread you're in LA every time you
go out to eat no get the bread basket
away yeah why are we the generation that
can eat bread we've been eating over
thousands of years all of a sudden we
show up and you can't have it no you can
if it's good stuff and good products you
can eat it these people have been eating
horrible stuff from the supermarket with
32 ingredients in it flour water salt
and yeast yeah
if you someone makes you good bread yes
you're not gonna get fatter
you're not gonna crash it's gonna be fat
are you gonna be good are you sure I'm
sure
I baked it now I've gotten a little out
of hand I baked it all the time more
than my family can even eat and no one's
gaining weight no one's getting fat
we're just eating it in the right amount
are you saying Tom Papa you did not gain
weight shooting baked I'm saying that
you you actually you're the maintainer
you maintained ah yeah I gained a little
I went up and down that's a roller
coaster it really is there were some
days when you really just be eating
everything and it was I got a new bag
that can fit running shoes in the back
yeah I didn't know he's used them but
just carrying them around made me feel
like all right baked is premiering on
Food Network coming up on Labor Day on
Monday night so the Yankees are yeah
correct
they are my team now what are you where
do you where do you stand right now on
the Yankee season Tom we the Red Sox are
gonna they're starting to drop like a
stone it's amazing it's and they all
feel it uh all my Red Sox fans they know
it's coming yeah I can feel it yeah all
of a sudden a little losing streak it's
starting to happen six games back here
we come
oh it's gonna be so I know summer they
tortured us we kept winning kept winning
done I wouldn't pay attention to the Red
Sox we'd be on a winning streak check
the standings still ten back I'm like
what are they doing up there I know you
know what they were doing burning
themselves out
well you've got a Masshole across the
studio look he knows he know it's yeah
but it's different though Tommy I know
that I've been having fun with Chris
explain this was 2003 it'd be a
different story
you'd be panicking different right you
guys you guys remember happened in 2000
you don't tell me that you still have a
little of that leftover socks DNA feels
like we might be I'm more worried about
Tom Brady see the but that's also true
to it like if this was 2003 they were
still talking about you know the war of
1812 the last time that the Red Sox had
one
there was only one Lombardi in the
trophy case right at that point in time
right or yeah a season was there next
one mm for calendar year there's only
one trophy in the case the Boston angst
was still there yeah I'm trying to and
and it's out 1970 the 1978 Boston
Massacre 40 year anniversary that's
totally lost on him I was with my
brother-in-law he's a lifelong Red Sox
fan and he's the same thing oh we're fat
and happy oh we have our things it's not
the same and then you're sitting at
dinner and I'm like all right six and a
half back and you see the flicker in his
highs it's like you know you know if
your dad spanks you when you're little
you'll talk about it in therapy for the
rest of your life you can walk around
town saying I don't care it's cool Tom
Brady you know it's coming Yankees have
the White Sox tonight yeah if they win
they're five and a half back they're
just fought back in the loss column hear
me out Chris then then but the Marlins
stroll into town yeah with Jose Urania
first up fresh off of his uh tout win
meanwhile so who would he whose elbow is
he gonna hunt first mm the bookie bets
he put 1 1 but bets his chops just to
start the game what do you think all
right so Mookie's out then then it'll be
four back yeah
back I'm gonna count ago in September
1900 in my mind in this scenario yeah
Sanchez didi Gregorius and Aaron judge
with half a month are all are all bad
players of the month of September yeah
they're all rested coming back strong
[ __ ] good you know what it you know what
this this confidence comes from the
bread and knowing that you're telling me
I'm not gonna gain any weight when I eat
it like Henry the eighth just off the
top it's just the second loaf of bread
it's about what it's about seven inches
long five inches wide it's a huge
rectangle I could just take a bite out
of it and it's not even know it's made
with natural yeast so it's already
eating its own sugars you're gonna be
fine
by the way that's Arden is that our new
fantasy a new fantasy named natural
yeast Tom has been a lot of fun man
thanks so also your podcast come to pop
on the pop is still rockin and your your
and I got a new book your new book on
Amazon your dad stole my rate what's
that about it's about family life it's
broken down everyone in family fathers
mothers cousins
crazy aunts uncles you stole asses how's
your rake ever been stolen your dad
stole my rake and his family dilemma
okay very good and then you're touring
across North America Portland Maine the
Greenwich the Greenwich odium West
Hampton and then the Comedy Works in
Denver Colorado Tom Papa dot-com /
hashtag tour that's how you can get your
ticket oh he's out there good to see you
man you too
any time you come back by the way radio
audience Tom papa wearing the exact
outfit I had on Friday show people have
said we look alike classes right now Tom
and Matthew berry never been in the same
job but stop but we're not like the
Jacksons okay I don't want to hear it at
Tom pop on Twitter I follow you you're
fun you're fun follow I always love
having you on your tongue likewise go
Giants you got it the New York Giants as
well oh yeah you know I think the TV
only segment we might be able to show
the Instagram
story we got the Giants wanna nuts in
the locker room about Odell bean sign
really he's a rich man 95 million bucks
my old Z 25 you that that will pay for a
lot of rings when you're proposing to a
kicking net a lot of imaginary rings and
you're proposing to a kicking net good
to see her brother you too thank you
we're back with the latest from the
Giants camp in a moment the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience